[Music]
like it when we get to talk about
whatever we want because like you know I
hate who Tommy zoo kid I wanna like if I
was in school I would bully the [ __ ] out
of them like a real kid or is he like a
mean it's it's a meme oh yeah I can't
dude there's like a thirty minute video
of him like doing a kazoo tutorial and
yeah but there's not there's no talent
to play cuz it wait you're hating on him
cuz he's what do you mean there's no
time do you get a job kid
what do you mean there's no talent it's
an old video there's no talent you just
hum right no dude look there's a lot to
it yeah you got to also be able to see
on key some of the the lengths are these
kids are wild those little things
there's one way it's like uh when
someone someone you hate is talking [ __ ]
and it's like a little bee loop that
he's like what did this mom make him do
that probably he was part of those like
child actors I feel so bad for them me
too man cuz you know in the back of moms
like you better be [ __ ] happy yeah
man you better you better do this Johnny
this is why dad and they're all like
they're like okay action
hey everyone
yeah even the Cheerios be a child actor
he wants he wants to yeah that's
different cuz he wants to yeah so I
would if he wanted to but we had that
conversation we were trying to really
like go through the rolodex of all the
[ __ ] child actors that we knew about
or of and we were like which one hasn't
had problems like can you guys name one
who uh Doogie isn't Doogie doing okay so
he went through a crack probably said
okay now right Justin Timberlake and
then Lizzie McGuire Lizzie McGuire she's
no she's disappeared dude nobody talked
about her to about how she was like
putting her neighbor on blast
that Hilary Duff that's like light not
bad she's not appeared for a minute we
don't know why why Hilary Duff right
yeah she kind of drama surrounding her
and you know what is it what is doing
all right me like still have a career no
meeting likely not Lindsay Lohan that
mentally ill yeah even JT did something
wrong he also dated Britney Spears who
went but then he also cut it off by
right when I was getting serious no he
cut it off right when she was hurting
really like right before she turned
shave your head so maybe he recognized
maybe he's the only one that got pink
taco would do perfectly fine because
he's surrounded by people that are
awesome but the problem with these child
actors is not them it's their parents
think about the type of people that make
their kids child actors it's like stage
moms you know to me or like those
[ __ ] beauty pageant you hear a lot
about those parents dealing money from
their yeah what the [ __ ] is that good
yeah at this point I can play the
boulder in Indiana Jones yeah you see my
tweet about my back though big round
head yes the density of a dying son dude
like no
I said imagine carrying a fat raccoon
that's hugging a bowling ball that's
exactly what Carrington feels like she's
got the craziest hair yeah dude and then
someone asked me like what's carrying
laya like I'm like imagine carrying a
bag of pink cotton candy with a toupee
on what if you know that the end is
almost guaranteed crazy and but he wants
to act when he's eight you're still
gonna let him well cuz that to me is the
same thing that's the same thing that's
the whole football thing we're like I've
known of so much there's so much studies
of not just professional football
players but college and even high school
that have so much head trauma
that it causes depression suicidal
thoughts all that stuff but I'm like
when you hold someone back from their
passion that's like one of the worst
things you can so you might like if they
want to
he's passionate about heroin do you know
you're a new age your new age moment cuz
I just know ha I just know how we're
pressed I felt in like how like
suffocated I felt growing up I think
it's a balance though it probably is
there is but my person wouldn't probably
let me play football but they let me
play basketball
and I think the balance comes from
letting them do that so I think like the
more you or you can't play football or
you can't be a child actor then they get
like this frustration but once you
actually let them do it
they act they find their own balance I
think people leave they go oh wait this
is too much I'm gonna smash in the face
wait so much that's so true because I
think he really wanted us to like pursue
him trying to be an actor like you
really like that so remember when you
drew that picture like you wanted to be
an actor yeah and then so whenever we
would something up that's my like the
whole vlogging thing was kind of like
alright let's test the water see how you
are but then every time that the camera
turns on now the older that he's getting
the more conscious he is of himself and
especially because he knows that his
friends watches our vlogs and his
friends like comment on it when he he
goes to school so then like all that
gets his head so now every time he's
just like like you know I'm not really
feeling
like I'm okay with not being me oh
that's perfect and you go even further
and record them even more yeah pushing
pushing traumatized oh [ __ ] out of here
and then say it's just a prank bro yeah
you know I think the best thing is to
never be the enemy so you let them do
whatever the [ __ ] they want but you
sabotage the [ __ ] out of their
experience like the one where they find
like the dad you'll find a carton or
cart what is it a cigarette yeah and
then he goes oh you want one yeah here
man
and he gives it to me it's like not yet
that I have to smoke the whole box like
that
no cuz you'll be the bad guy cuz you're
forcing him to smoke the hole so you
gotta be like oh you want to be an actor
alright that's cool and then you bring
them on set to like a horror film or
something or like something that
dramatizes the [ __ ] out of them a crazy
for yeah yeah well I don't know porno
sounds awesome
a bad porno Oh your son's into geriatric
porn yeah I think that's like that's
exactly what happened to me to look for
did not happen to me but I know that
time and I remember when like when they
wouldn't let me
like when I couldn't go out so I kept
sneaking out and they're like alright go
ahead and I come over at 9 p.m. or like
when I asked my mom like hey well no I
told him I'm like I'm gonna get a tattoo
she's like cool it's good some matching
ones I'm just like oh that's pretty good
nevermind
Joe's theory that's pretty good yeah you
just gotta let the kids do it and then
they find their own balance
I mean think of all the responsible
young people that actually take care of
their shitty parents you see that's what
you gotta do is become shitty parents
and then they'll be responsible it
forces them to grow up yeah [ __ ] ton of
drugs yeah there's no recipe cuz all
that goes one way or the other like
right like someone has like yeah abusive
parents and you become the nicest human
in the world or you become a [ __ ]
can make you hate alcohol forever or
make your sober yeah yeah
one thing is I hear very common we're
like parents go overboard on the first
one and they're trying to control
everything but by the fifth one they
don't give a [ __ ] yeah yeah not enough
love you've been there done that and
then there's not enough time well the
kids end up turning out different to you
because the different stages different
you just don't have kids you don't have
these issues yeah but you never have to
so scared of having kids I swear to God
there was like no perfect formula of
like raising them
that's why not giving a [ __ ] is the
perfect formula that's not we just
talked about that could not work kidding
I can't wait till you have kids manikin
me yeah even last week what Aiko but you
are training there's like dog food in
our garage so he's just like walking
around and he's look there he wasn't
there but the minute he sees it's
awesome and I'm like son-of-a-bitch this
one wants to eat it cuz it looks like
it's next right
thank you that's like going hobbling
over there I can see his little hand
going there like slow motion and I move
his hand out the way and he's stubborn
so I can move it out of the way if ever
he doesn't know what that means oh well
I'll move it out of the way like 20
times and then I'll let him pick it up
and I thought maybe that would satisfy
the curiosity and go like this like 20
times and I keep moving it no it tastes
like [ __ ]
you want this see you just watch this
all that you can't you you can't control
them some experience it he'll make his
uncle but it doesn't work because then
he was in the same shirt with feathers
cuz our couch is nice don't let him eat
the feather [ __ ] feather you can't do
that it would that lessen it doesn't
work with everything though gravity yeah
yeah like all going on top of the roof
dude yeah loot on yourself bread I think
120 kids and the other 19 kids will buy
that guys down my hair or I was told
when I was little nozzle touching
mousetraps and a little like why why I
won't touch them so bad I wouldn't tell
you why they're like no you're not
supposed to touch that it's like it's
bad like it'll hurt you or whatever I'm
like oh it won't so they literally told
you what it was gonna do the most they
did tell you drawer I found one the back
their joint I stuck my finger in it holy
and I didn't want to get in Joel's I
didn't scream I was
yeah it was bad it was super bad control
is amused uh I'd be like [ __ ] it beat my
ass as long as you get this pain knob
that things meant to like snap a rat's
tail and right my fingernail - dude she
was bad yeah I think I was just a [ __ ]
as a kid I didn't do any of that stuff
like I was never the kid like oh I'm
gonna shove my hand electrical weren't
curious
I don't think so did I think it was kind
of hurt myself when I was little I I
wasn't consciously like I don't want any
scars so I just never did you've always
been like that
yeah I'm like I don't want to bust up my
skull she's like wait I'm not gonna
laugh I don't wanna know cuz I wanted to
be a mom since I was four I was like a
can't have scars because I want to be a
models I never did it in crazy
I thought scars were so dope I wanted
scars everywhere I thought it was cool -
where did you want to start action
movies I wanted a big one right here
like the villain scar I just Lion King
yeah cuz I wanted to be a brown scars
were kind of cool like the one I like
break up yours yeah I always wonder how
people got those shaving you know talk
about the trend claim oh thanks people
to get a scar right here but I don't
know how that happens
I've been if I'm fighting or something
yeah maybe a brain will they bust your
brows just it just I mean you have a
scar here accident I know but I guess
this is a bullet I'm thinking like the
Jason Momoa I brought this car yeah yeah
yeah ha no you're just talking about
Jesus
he's a beautiful glass of water like
Jesus Christ my god man I hope Tiger
turns out like that weird what would you
like I don't want to think cuz I'm right
for not thinking like that he's a manly
man he's like a beautiful why could you
watch your kids to make you horny mind
was going and then you threw in taiko
they won't you get mad at me if your
mind is thinking like that since mine
she's already wearing lingerie in front
of Jason and then turn it to Tigers
Mamola brought back the eyeliner the guy
lighter dude he was island in the
natural he's uh what's my call it to you
i Game of Thrones no I think he's where
he's Isla I think he wears eyeliner in
the in the Game of Thrones he wears yeah
that's eyeliner you ain't foolin me bro
that's a fake ass scar too he shaved it
in there people do that Chris Hemsworth
no no bring it down oh no he's in the
first one too well if I ignore some
simply with the with the dread law and
the orange eyeball dawg he was so
beautifully in being the first black
James Bond ya know a sexy man wait
Thor's gonna be James Bond yeah with the
hammer dude no pistols
just output the gatekeeper yeah all the
black guy black dude yeah yeah yes so
beautiful in that movie dude y'all just
in general yeah he's great
I want him like have you guys ever seen
someone character in a movie you just
want them to dress like that forever
like like cooking cosplay yeah like like
a like yo mother I want him to look like
that forever I don't know Michael B Wade
you like the scars no you like the sorta
hair and that the girls are coming back
I don't care for but then like all
everything up here I felt that way about
you that's really what there's a culture
it actually scars themselves I felt that
way about the first Tomb Raider yeah
yeah just walk around with guns like
that it's just booty shorts in a
freaking the tank maybe they'd say
that's it yeah but I mean there's girls
that do that it's like for cosplay and
it looks good I just watched it on the
airplane what do you think I just
watched a rampage before it which is
probably the worst movie I've ever seen
and so then watching that tumor goes
like this deserts of wars is the best
goddamn movie ever
yeah she's the same chick from ex
machina she doesn't look like a robot
but that's her acting Oh cata me
award-winning actress - I don't know for
what movie though I like ex machina but
she was it was fine it was fine yeah I
was like it's entertaining was it was a
little fun huh it was he I was fine it
was a good airplane movie yeah certain
types of movies you can't like go on for
it right like Adam Sandler's and these
Jim Carrey's that were crushing and ice
like you can't make a movie like that
right now it looks so corny yeah but I
didn't like even like that like the Tomb
Raider II whatever like you can't make
those type of movies anymore I feel like
they don't that's too much of a theme is
that what makes it cheesy
maybe maybe because I think was hitting
hard right now I was like whatever's
like the REIT likes more real
- like right now - today like the way we
act the way we speak the things that we
go through our decisions that we make I
feel like those are the movies oh yeah
Benjamin G that's why I think was so
good because it was it's such a crazy
world out there in video game days yeah
it's a it's literally a game but then it
was it was like a really good movie I
really liked it
you've never seen the real one yeah he
said he never saw the real one you ever
seen anybody
Oh Robin Williams the first Jumanji I
barely watched mrs. Doubtfire this year
it's Dell fires amazing time it was
amazing I feel like if you name any
movie up until like 2000 Bart didn't see
it yes so sorry I never watched it I
never was like 2005 I've never watched
it when when I was should've watched
we're watching Jumanji tonight you'll
still like it
Jumanji the first one I think is still
better than the new one well they see
them as two separate like completely
separate they're not in the same that's
true it doesn't even connect I agree
yeah I wish it did though that would be
really cool I'm glad it did it because
the first one so good yeah true it would
have killed it for me I would have been
like why did you waste my [ __ ] time
the first one was way better the second
one is just the curse that's all it is
it's a whole new movie they should
almost an uneven College of hockey they
should have called it seven different
just like made of like Jumanji yeah not
you mangy you should have called in non
Jumanji I liked it though that they went
into the Jumanji world instead of
Jumanji world coming into our waters do
you ever see the question like a Jumanji
cartoon yeah and they went in there yeah
there's like a hunter guy yeah Jumanji
starts sounds starts sounding really
weird when you say it a lot Jumanji too
much a bunch of mine did you mind gee
Jumanji don't even mean where's it come
from hey how do people make up these
words I wanna make up or is it is it a
word that's made up it could be real
yeah words are made I mean like I think
it's deep
a little meat car that I mean you think
though I got it from one it because
we've been watching Marvel movies since
the first one my god the whole MTU
universe you've been buying each one
that's tight
the most recent one I think was the
adventures no oh no the one that we're
watching in ordered which Avengers the
first one Oh Avengers and I think in
that movie I forgot but one of the
movies or that one are the ones before
someone said that quote like all words I
made oh no it was the last Avengers cuz
we also have the last one we started
that Oh God
the point is that home all words are
made up I got from one of the Marvel
movies
I'll speak of which has son years has
Casey his elitist [ __ ] ass has he
seemed
well I'm his wife in a coup your pain
it's [ __ ] a tumble the time get off
your high horse of your movies like oh
my god has he seen my pants again do you
like it did you [ __ ] I don't know did
you see my thought in the plane I loved
and then I fix out on the plane - and
he's like Danny you gotta watch it I
don't know if he has it's good I dude
that dude from Sacramento yeah he was a
sex date which one the director he also
directed a Fruitvale station love with
him samesies who's me and everything
that was a sexy man - if he told me I
saw my first child I'd do it for him is
there an Asian a Marvel or DC character
there was in there was that's not a side
character sidekick Kate or was it I are
there trying to remake that under green
lantern I think use mantas yeah well
there's that one guy from yeah yeah
she's alright there's that guy from a
Wolverine Daniel Henney played on yeah
zero
Agent Zero Agent Zero agent zero and
then Amy's bill with guns right because
they're not ton of Asian villains and
there is x-men where the guy
let's who's [ __ ] Jintao's blog shaved
head ass [ __ ] remember and oh okay
this is the porcupine yeah the dude
[ __ ] lame he died there's a asian
porcupine and his power was just spines
come be on his body doctor Strange's
homies those dope oh yeah looking at and
he's like pretty relevant in the newest
one I didn't watch Doctor Strange its
period after a while you can't like
alright I'm out and there's never came
back some [ __ ] yeah he didn't really
fight he was dealt though he said Doctor
Strange is maurella was it played by
Benedict Wong I don't know he's got like
uh I don't know maybe he's cool he's in
a
the [ __ ] Marco Polo Netflix series
never seen it that's crazy
Danny give up but these are Mexican one
is there a Mexican Marvel character oh
my god Louise hello the dude and Ant Man
that tells all the stories he's not a
hero the show every [ __ ] time every
story to me ever did you know I was
disappointed you know he's a
Scientologist Oh ruin it for me or do
you think he's really a saint yeah I
don't think you can have a Scientologist
no no I mean like you're playing the
game because you know I don't think so
yeah you really like Chloe I think so
kind of killed it for me like I've seen
that documentary was it coming clear oh
yeah
oh that's a big old for me dawg
I only want to be in Scientology if I'm
on the top I don't you want to be in
there I don't even wanna be in there I
don't know what it takes to get to the
top yeah you probably have to like kill
everything kill everyone but you love it
well I don't want to climb I just want a
free pass in and I'm like wearing a
captain outfit make it start making
rules yeah
[Music]